We've now learned how to access our data,
tidying it up, and transforming it to create queries that we need.
What we've done so far is the extract and
transform portion of extract, transform, and load.
Now, it's time to close and load
our carefully structured queries so they become available as tables in Power BI.
Every step that we've taken up to this point is to pave
the path for the data model that we're about to put together.
This lesson is about creating the relationships between
our tables and building the complete data model that we'll need for our report,
then using those relationships to create filters.
We'll also create calculations through what Power BI refers
to as measures using data analytics expressions,
more commonly known as DAX.
These enrich our reporting and enhance our visualizations.
The functional steps that we took to organize and
structure our data in the Power Query model,
means that we have already created the types of tables that we need.
These are a fact table that is long and
thin with just the aggregatable data and the key columns that we need,
one or more dimension tables that are short and fat,
just with the descriptive data and a unique key listed for each row,
which facilitates the relationship between the dimension and fact table,
and we also have that date dimension table.
This contains one row per day,
which serves as our unique date key and customized columns for
whatever time data we need for our reporting needs such as fiscal calendar weeks,
months, day of the week, and so on.
Recall from the last lesson that we learned that an important step
after making your date table is to mark it as a date table.
Otherwise, our time intelligence won't work as designed in Power BI.
We'll do this first thing during our demo.
As with our other dimension tables,
we'll use the date key to build a relationship between
the date dimension table and the fact table as well.
At this stage, we've also identified data types for our columns within our tables,
which we'll also refer to as fields,
especially once we get to the reporting pane.
The main ones we'll encounter are the date-time data types,
the text string data type,
and the number data types.
These data types will define how each column can be used for various filters.
We'll also talk about measures. What is a measure?
Measures are the ways that we express any of
our aggregatable facts or values in reporting context.
We've already discussed how in Power BI,
there's no such thing as a cell.
This is an extension of this concept.
In the same way,
there's no number type field expressed independently.
All aggregatable values pull into
the reporting pane in a way that it has to be expressed as part of an aggregation,
including min, max, average,
or count among others.
In Power BI, measures fall into three kinds of categories.
We have our implicit DAX measures,
which populate automatically in the reporting pane.
By default of fact,
pulled onto the reporting pane will be expressed as a sum,
though you can always update this based on your needs.
We have quick DAX measures,
which leverage more complex logic than
implicit measures but are commonly used and readily available.
Then you have the option to create your own custom DAX measures.
Whenever people refer to measures in Power BI,
this is generally what they're referring to.
You can use DAX to either further customize quick measures or make your own measures.
For this lesson, we'll focus on two functions that make
good use of data model relationships and filtering, Calculate, and SumX.